[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bros
j'espère que tous nos petits amis ont
été sages aujourd'hui jean repos pas
trop d'accord mon bon nounours tu leur
montre ton beau livre d'image y moi je
vais le raconter une belle histoire je
coure patron aulas que je suis dit qu'on
joue mieux mon de cheveux tu es trop
distrait mon gros nounours bon le seul
propos bonsoir mushers au fond c'est un
chic à la lettre telle une histoire du
karma soir je vais vous montrer bon
livre d'image et notre ami le marchand
de sable va vous le raconte
c'est l'histoire de guillaume jugé
étudions mag mais oui allons mes neveux
alors venez écoutez moi avec nicolas et
à problèmes l'histoire comment au dessus
avoue patron l'hiver est passé
accompagné de son fidèle ami et en ayant
que fut le petit chinois revient du
marché dynamics est revenue kioukiou 9
où il est revenu dans le jardin de yang
chut chut avec tous ses amis les oiseaux
et quand ils arrivent ils chantent tous
en choeur pour lui dire bonjour ski
saint jacques
égouttez le sud le zoo fond il fait très
beau les premières feuilles commencent à
montrer le bout de leur nez
et notre petit chinois rapporte du
marché de merveilleux papiers de toutes
les couleurs qui l'a achetée au bord de
la rivière choisi de roseaux les plus
légers les attaches avec une ficelle
très longue
les recouvre avec ses papiers chinois
qu'ils collent soigneusement il voilà
que s'envolent mais oui et evolo de plus
en plus haut et on est très content car
le soleil le fait briller et il s'amuse
comme des fous et les petits oiseaux eux
aussi s'amuse et volent autour du
cerf-volant à la fin de la journée quand
la nuit est arrivé bien que juju attache
le cerf-volant à son plus haut cerisiers
et tout le monde va dormir quand tout à
coup
mais oui et on se met à crier très fort
car le vilain gros vilain est venue des
tâches et le cerf-volant
or celui là il commence à nous on petit
mais qui en fait un tel bruit que gros
vilain se sauver sans emporter de
cerfs-volants il va se cacher
villain oui mais notre petit chinois
court après son beau cerf-volant qui
s'est envolé au et ils montrent si haut
dans le ciel qu'il touche la lune mais
pilou pilou et tous les oiseaux du
jardin qui se sont réveillés le rattrape
et le ramène et ben nous si on recompte
gros villiers lui fera beau
nous lui dirons qu'il ne faut plus
recommencer à lons les enfants
l'histoire est finie auto mais nous on
va ce que j'ai tout seul
[Musique]
par les petits-enfants ça
à deux ans
[Musique]
oui
pète deboer heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants notre histoire vous a
plu
oui tant mieux ah non en route moins
cher nounours bonne nuit fais de beaux
rêves
à demain
en off on fait tout pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]